j'aime lui comme je l école je venais
coll
je n'aime pas l'école
je regrette licol
des repas 3
[Musique]
cette police
et
[Musique]
e
j'aime pas l'école parce que est assis
toute la journée dans une salle à ecouen
haboubi tout ce que peuvent se dissipe
maintien sont pas posés au système fait
l'école en elle-même c'est chaud c'est
sous la j'aime pas le cas je vais pas
mentir je le dis notamment parce que
franchement l'école j'avais pas d'ouvrir
c'est un casse tête mais il ya des
moments si difficiles surtout si on a
des difficultés partout le concept de
l'école ni par hbo c'est l'école a été
mal fait le fait de devoir rester dans
une salle à si peu de teasing journée
entre quatre murs ce n'est pas
intéressant
l'histoire joue on n'a pas besoin de
connaître l'histoire madame ils sont
tous maux on n'a pas besoin de savoir
comment ils vivaient au moyen âge
l'anglais madame nous sommes fiancés
autorités espagnoles séparer madame on
va ben ali je ne suis pas au pourquoi
l'espagne
des fois ce responsable après quel match
au physique chimie madame on va pas
devenu fou je sais pas moi
astrophysiciens jeu physique chimie ça
sert à rien donc on va pas pour une
physique chimie camacho locaux
qu'inutile gens quel match aux jeunes à
douter mais j'oublie économies mais
madame économie s'assied madame madame
économie c'est pas genre du jour au
lendemain vous allez devenir banquier
puis vous allez ici de je sais pas moi
de faire des économies sur votre compte
bancaire madame ça sert à rien
sport aux mathématiques et de français
la matière que j'aime le plus 6% pour
faire ce pour tout le temps je pense que
jouer pour mon pied
quand
[Applaudissements]
je
faux
comment ne pas aimer d'école c'est ne
pas aimer son avenir quand il va les cas
c'est pour construire son avenir sans
décor tu peux pas aller travailler
c'est en allant à l'école que je vais
pouvoir me avoir les diplômes pour voir
votre travail mais bon s'il y avait une
autre façon de travailler
et puis avant son diplôme sans aller à
l'école souhaitez moi j'aime pas les
call of et j'aime l'école mais en même
temps nous c'est s'énervant c'est
fatigant mais pour ici ou dans la vie il
faut être à l'école et si on ne va pas à
l'école
c'est aussi dire ce qui va se passer
c'est la wii
[Musique]
me lever tôt pour aller à l'école le
réveil le fait d'autres quittant le soir
quand on est très fatigué donc on va
directement dormir des fois même sans
manger on passe plus de temps à l'école
que avec notre famille pour notre notre
enfance on nous dit juste que ca va nous
servir au poids près mais où la môme
opposent par peur on fera ça maintenant
six mois qu'avait créé l'école je fais
déjà en pleine et au tuba foncé mois à 6
ans que de gober tout ce que la pauvre
thalys et c'est plus amusant qu'autre
chose du sol s'est pas enfermé c'est là
on aurait pu être des kiosques et puis
le que ce soit un peu aménagés pour cela
quand on est la nature
on va encore dit voir par exemple une
bête passé ou bien on peut voir nos buts
comme ça on peut être en cours mais
stoppé dix fois ses taux d'un coup pour
parler de notre notre fait pas notre vie
personnelle mais aujourd'hui c'est
comment ça se passe excité là on le fait
avec un professeur mais ça ne suffit pas
en fait il faut que plusieurs
professions le fasse aussi
[Musique]
il venait d'entrer en fusion j'avais eu
un fils parce que c'est moi qui faisais
les bêtises elle a pris la rive d'un
mètre mais elle m'a même pas fait mal
mais je vois que c'est une injustice que
si je me fais plus new look que je ne
sais pas moi donc ça m'a dégoûté à la
maternelle en moyenne section je me
souviens que certaines fois il y avait
des camarades à moi qui faisait des
bêtises mais la plupart du temps ça a
retrouvé tout aussi voir il ya la longue
je vois que chaque année ça soit on
toujours sur moi donc je me suis dit
pourquoi c'est moi c'est la justice ça
commençait au cp j'ai eu beaucoup de
difficulté aussi jusqu'à remplace le 6e
j'ai eu des difficultés au niveau de la
lecture parce que j'arrivais pas bien
lyon et je vois doubler au moins deux
classes ou trois classes de la sixième
des gîtes difficultés au collège donc et
j'ai redoublé
[Applaudissements]
j'étais une élève assez calme un peu
trop gentil
alors parfois les camarades profite un
peu le match qui s je suis quelqu'un qui
aime pas fait dans mon coin et pas
comment dirais-je bienvenue à des gens
qui pour poser pour s'amuser 10 pouces
pour s'amuser dise du mal des autres il
faut deux fois ils font du mal aux
autres pour relais pas l'école des fois
quand on se fait critiquer tout le temps
au final ça fait qu'on n'a pas d'amis
ebooks
ça fait qu'on n'aime pas l'école non
plus
[Musique]
sa vie est en train de rempoter de bel
abbès débat est gratuit
magnien with you je n'ai pas choisi au
troisième je travaille pas d'autre pour
mon orientation va miner partout que
l'année dernière dans mon ancienne ici
j'avais des profs qui n'arrivait pas
franchement à me faire comprendre des
choses que je comprenais pas c'est à
dire expliquer mais on a aimé mais pas
ceux qui nagent ils n'avaient jamais le
temps pour les élèves donc ça veut dire
que si tu n'as pas compris si ton
problème tu restes herriot au fait je me
suis retrouvé dans cette filière parce
que en troisième je n'ai pas fourni le
travail décision pour aller de la
section je voulais je ne travaillais pas
du tout je faisais qu'à ma musique mais
bon après ce n'est de la faute de
personne c'est de ma faute
on fait de la pratique profit de l'ape
de l'aménagement paysager
après j'aime du saphir parce que j'aime
la nature tu vois je je vais t'acheter
paysagisme où je suis obligé de passer
par là et puis si nous mettrons tout est
de ma nature tu vois les chants des
oiseaux
ça fait limite
ça c'est unique et du gabon donc là on
allie et bourgeons si je peux dire
mais voilà sur la peau qu'ont fleuri
mais si on encore plus haut
ça a déjà plus ça s'est un peu assagie
[Applaudissements]
je veux être honnête c'est ce pays qui
veut dire assistance à la personne
c'est ce qui m'intéresse et j'aimerais
changer de section si possible j'aime
bien ce point de sons et de certaines
personnes j'ai encore des personnes
âgées ou des enfants tout simplement y
on va dire je suis affectueux
j'aime ce sont des gens tout simplement
mes projets pour l'avenir c'est de
devenir assistante de puériculture aux
néo natalogie c'est à dire travailler
que les bébés prématurés les eaux faut
ce sont des petits êtres vivants
innocent et s'aimer revue parce que par
rapport à ce qu'ils font comme ils sont
c'est quelque chose c'est nature humaine
qui est très magnifique je vais
travailler pour halo 1 9% que technicien
forestier pouvoir être en extérieur plus
fort mais shipton contre les animaux
tout ça puis avoir de quoi me nourrir de
gamme et logi être heureux
vu que moi j'ai fait un grand river mon
projet c'est de faire évoluer mon île
mais aussi la planète s'il le faut par
rapport à son avis one là affaire à
faire changer les choses à faire bouger
les choses mais surtout développer
l'internet harmonie
[Musique]